okay welcome back to Gary's economics
today we are going to explain why the
rich get
richer all right so I was talking the
other day to a good friend of mine a a
Dutch guy who I studied economics with
um back at Oxford when I was doing my
masters in 17 to 19 and um when I was at
Oxford I was very adamant very adamant
that the Eon the economy would get worse
and worse for ordinary people living
standards would fall because inequality
was increasing and increasing now this
is not a popular idea in modern
University academic economics and this
guy sort of was quite skeptical at the
time but it's obviously been five or six
years since then and he and I and you
have seen inequality inequality
massively increase and living standards
massively decrease and he's got started
to be convinced that I'm correct which
um if you stick with my channel for long
enough and keep seeing my predictions be
right hopefully you'll be too so he
messaged me the other day and he was
like look I think you're right
inequality is just destroying the
economy um I think it's
important we need to do something about
it but he asked me why is it that
suddenly now in the last 20 years 10
years especially the last 5 years why is
inequality increasing now what is
actually causing the increase inequality
uh and I thought that was a really
interesting question something that was
worth discussing and explaining on the
channel so I think the first thing you
need to know in order to answer that
question is that for the vast majority
of human history at least in the last
2,000 years human societies have been
extremely unequal and living standards
have been in most cases very very low it
was only really after the second world
war that inequality decreased
significantly in parts of the world here
in the UK in Western Europe North
America places like Japan
but of course in the rest of the world
inequality stayed very high and living
stand stayed very low but if you go back
and look before World War II basically
most of history is extremely unequal
societies so I think in order to answer
the question why is inequality Rising
now you first need to understand that
really it is the last 70 years that are
the exception what we have had is an
exceptional period only in C places
which is that Western Europe North
America Japan Australia a few other
places have had historically very un
very equal low inequality societies for
70 years and very high living standards
that's not normal that didn't
exist almost ever basically it was a
specific period so the reason that I
mentioned that is it's not actually
something unusual that is happening now
that inequality is becoming very large
this is actually the
norm so I think if we look at human
history we kind of have to accept that
human societies tend towards very high
levels of inequality and we have a few
examples in the last 70 years of places
where that didn't happen so let's
discuss why it happens why the
inequality grows in the context of this
basically always
happens and what I said to my friend was
really really it's very simple so you
can look at it in the very specific case
which is in our societies that we live
in now what happens is you go to work
you get paid your 30 40 Grand a year you
spend almost all of it on rent mortgage
food bills and it goes towards the
owners of the properties the owners of
the debt the owners of the production of
the things that you need which is
essentially rich people so you go to
work you make 40 Grand you give it all
to rich people they use that to buy the
rest of the assets
it's a relatively simple Dynamic I've
spoken about it a lot on the channel but
this is the specific case I think what
this is is a specific example of
basically a more General concept which
is when power is unequally distributed
people who have a lot of power which in
our society basically means rich people
can use that power to dispossess the
less powerful so in our society that
means rich people use your salary which
you've paid to them they give it to
their kids they buy their kids buy your
house your kids don't have a house but
you know this could manifest differently
in different ways this is simply a
specific case of the general rule that
when power is unequal the powerful can
can dispossess the weak and this leads
very naturally to an accumulation of
power I'm powerful you're not I use that
power to take your stuff and you can see
this happen if you look throughout sort
of the history of medieval Europe what
you saw was for a period there was lots
of small states and then when certain
kingdoms became powerful they used that
power to take the kingdoms around them
it's another example of this you
know this is why human history tends
towards high levels of inequality
because once you have inequality then
the rich can use their power to
dispossess the weak and that's all of
history that's all of history that that
is what happens in human societies if
you look at the history of human
societies human societies have always
been very unequal except for War one
period in time 70 years after the second
world war when a lot of societies
suddenly became much more equal why was
that I think you the best clue I always
remember there's a song by The Beatles
I'm a big fan of The Beatles first time
I mention that on the channel called tax
man yeah one of the opening lines of the
song it's written from the perspective
of the tax man which says one for you 19
for me and this is because the Beatles
at the peak of their success were paying
95% top in income tax rate in the UK now
I'm not advocating for a 95% top income
tax rate uh the top inheritance tax rate
at the time was was 90% during that
period up until the 80s specifically we
had in Western Europe and also In
America which has a reputation as a low
tax Society up until the 80s we had
extremely high tax rates on the very
rich um and that basically prevented the
rich from rapidly
accumulating wealth of of the rest of
their countries that is the exception
that is the exception if you have
systems that prevent the rich and the
powerful from taking the wealth and
power of the poor then you can prevent
it if you don't have those systems you
can't prevent it so the reason that
inequality is increasing is that the
rich are very powerful and they can they
can use the income that they get from
you to take the rest of the stuff and
this is always the way it has been and
it's always the way it will
be but I don't want to be excessively
fatalistic here cuz I see people in the
comments all the time saying it was
always like that it was always like that
listen we had 70 years when it was not
like that we had 70 years when
inequality was unusually low in a lot of
countries especially you know most of
the countries of Western Europe and that
was 70 years in which postmen and
cleaners and hairdressers could buy
houses and go on holidays and raise
families and afford space this is not
the norm this is this is not the norm
but we had that because we had very high
rates attack on wealthier people listen
you you need that you if you you need to
have structures in place in your economy
that prevent the rich from taking all of
the wealth if you don't have that
history teaches us the rich get all of
the wealth and once the rich have all of
the wealth not just history but the
present World shows us
ordinary people end up with very poor
living conditions you know if you go to
countries that are very unequal if you
go to I mean it's it's most of the world
to be honest you go to place like India
South Africa you know almost anywhere in
Latin America very unequal societies
lead to very poor living standards um
this is the norm we prevented it before
um we prevented it by leving very high
tax rates on the very very rich
so you know I know I see people in the
comments all the time accusing me of
being a communist because I want High
tax rates on the rich listen I'm a
Trader in my heart of hearts I made a
lot of money betting on this um I'm
still betting on it now my firm belief
is that if you don't tax rich people
living standards collapse for ordinary
people um it's happening now it will
continue to happen we can reverse it but
we need to tax the rich and I'm not I'm
not talking about you Dave in the
comments who's an accountant making 60
Grand I'm talking about families with
with 10 million1 million p in assets if
you don't tax them they'll take
everything that includes all of your
assets your kids will be poor your
grandkids will be poor you w Inn
anything you need to protect yourself
from the people who are taking your
assets that is the rich we're fighting
against it support the channel educate
yourself educate your friends educate
your family if enough people say no we
can change it just like we changed it
after World War II but it needs enough
people to step forward and push back I'm
pushing I hope you'll push too thank you
very much